The Joe Rogan experience. Yeah. People get
too comfortable, you know? It's just, it,
it's only their fans. There's
preaching to the fan base. Yeah.
We've got like Bill Maher is not changing
anyone's mind. Just like people are,
people are applauding there.
They know they're going to apply
before they even get there. Yeah.
I would never do a comedy club. He
looks in the comedy clubs at all. No,
I'm sure he does not. Yeah. Yeah. I
think, yeah. I think you really have to.
Yeah. No, I think so too. Yeah. Well,
he's in this weird category too, right?
Where he's not just doing comedy.
He's got to do,
everything has to be political because
this whole thing is about political,
political shit. Like his show is
his persona, who he is, you know,
he donated $1 million to the Democratic
Party. Like he's, it's all politics. Oh,
all of it. And I can't stand
political humor just because
it's just, it's so easy.
You know?
You're either,
you're either making everyone mad or
you're making everyone really happy,
but it doesn't really matter like what
the joke is. Yeah. You know? Yeah, yeah,
yeah. It's, uh,
and then if you're doing stuff about
like the speaker of the house and you're
like, God, when someone's like, should the
Mueller report, it's like, fuck man. Like,
no.
Yeah.
You know who's like super deep into
politics on the right is nick depaulo like
every time I talked to him yeah.
And wants to talk about the fucking
Steele dossier. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's talk about all this different,
all the Shit Obama did. Well,
how about when Obama did this? Yeah. How
do you know? Yeah, I don't even know this.
I know that the,
the knowledge of it,
like I once got a phone call before
the last election, like a, you know,
a year ago and they're like,
we want to ask you about like,
how involved would you say are you with
politics? And I'm like, very, actually,
I'm pretty passionate right now. Um, and
like, how informed would you say you,
I'm like, I'm at 10, very
informed and then like, okay.
And they start asking me questions and
I did not know what the fuck they were
talking about. Like I hadn't heard of
any of these things. Any of these bills.
Like I have no idea.
I have no idea what's going on.
It's like the difference between a
casual sports fan and someone who really
understands all the drafts and all the
pics from different colleges and all with
this guy's got potential and this
guy needs to work on this defense.
This is a 40 times. Yeah. Yes. Yeah. The
people who know that combine numbers, Yay.
Bench press two 24 47 times.
There's people that know that stuff
and like it's exhausting because it,
it's so involved.
Like do you have to,
if you really want to be paying attention
to everything that's going on with
Nancy Pelosi, you know, you gotta,
you gotta be paying attention
to that all day long.
And most of the people that
do that, they're nuts. Like
you're, you're, it's just,
it's like sports, it's sports, but
in a different way. Like you're just,
this is the thing that you're wrapped
up in [inaudible] although it does shape
our world, you know? Yeah.
As far as like right wing comics go
though does not a lot of like Nick Depaulo
is the king because he's
actually really fucking funny.
Like he's right wing as
like a person and you know,
he's conservative but he's
also a great stand up comedian.
But did he get more right?
Yes. As he got older. Yeah.
So it wasn't all wet because I remembered
the Apollo. He's one of my favorites.
Uh, you know, when I would see him on TV
as a kid and I know him a little bit now,
but uh, the, the,
the right things seem to come up more
and more in the past 10 years. Yeah.
He was always in, yeah. Angry guy,
but he became like an old angry guy that's
really into politics as he got older.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I
guess part of it is like,
it works for them. Like
it's, people love to hear it.
Like there's not a lot of those guys,
like who does this right.
Have to bank on in terms of like
comics that they could go see good.
Tim Allen barely.
Does he do standup anymore?
I think he does like,
I think it goes up to the laugh
factory does he thinks yeah. Okay.
So maybe he's one of those guys are like,
when was the last time you want to say
six months ago? You know what I mean?
Oh yeah. You know what I mean? I don't, I
don't know, maybe I'm wrong, but who else?
Okay, so you got Tim Allen
and Nick Depalo. There's
gotta be more. There must be,
I mean Norton kind of leans right
a little bit more libertarian,
but he doesn't do a lot of politic jokes.
He'll talk about it.
But when the fuck else is like no one,
but if you want to do like left wing
commander and so you can start with
Michelle Wolf and work your way up. Oh
yeah. This, there's millions of them.
Michelle Wolf wasn't even like left wing.
I think the correspondents' dinner,
everyone's like, this is a star making
turn. And I think it almost ruined her.
Really? Yes. Because her show,
Netflix was called the break.
Like it was called the break and was like,
we're going to take a break from all
of this and just talk about like other
things going on in the world.
We don't need to be focused on politics.
And after that,
after the correspondence dinner,
it was like the opening show was like her
going after Sarah Huckabee Sanders and
you're like, oh, you, you got forced into
this. You know, we're not a niche. Yeah.